this is the first time you've you've
given an interview since you left
government what happened on that day
when you asked not to stay on his
business secretary well you know
reshuffles are always a bit of a fraught
time it's never much fun and that day
was not much fun for me it was it was a
personal blow but at the end of the day
we all serve at the behest of the prime
minister of the day how does he explain
to you that he no longer requires your
services it must be a bit of an awkward
conversation isn't it well I think you
know if you're giving someone difficult
news you just have to come out with it
you know I want you to step aside one
day everybody is asked to step down and
it just came too soon for my liking
you've had a number of very high profile
positions across government and in
cabinet you're someone who speaks their
mind as well I mean did you think there
was no longer room for that in
government I I don't know I mean I think
you know I I would say I do not know why
I was asked to step aside so you don't
know why why do you think he asked you
to step aside I mean you were vote lever
you'd worked on that campaign were you
just not part of the gang you know it's
it's it's impossible to know I mean I
you know I could could speculate for
hours but I'm you know if you spoke I
think your viewers might get bored I'm
going to bring it back to you and the
former Speaker John Barker he's
described you as bigoted deluded feeble
and sinister do you feel he bullied you
what I would say is I think his actions
speak for themselves and people will
form their own views things better in
the Commons do you think now he's gone I
think the mood of the House is lifted
much more collegiate in the house and I
think that the new Speaker Lindsey has
really presided over a change in
atmosphere which I really do welcome but
Andrew you had a job to do his leader of
the House he had the job to do as
Speaker why was there
this level of animosity what do you
think was going on how did you feel
about it all did you feel bullied by him
my experience was I was always
determined
to stand up to what I saw as
unacceptable behavior and that was how I
saw it at all times one person who's
very facing some very serious
allegations at the moment is your your
colleague Preeti Patel the Home
Secretary but most of your colleagues
have dismissed those allegations against
her out of hand
including the Prime Minister and do you
dismiss them as well
I myself have the greatest regard for
pretty I have never seen her ever bully
someone so I from my own experience I
have never seen her in the kind of
position that she's accused of but
equally I think the problem is it's
extremely difficult once these things
get into the public domain for anyone to
have a proper conversation about it so I
think confidentiality is absolutely
critical in any proper investigation and
also just find you on that before I move
on to something else do you think the
finding should be published
well again you see this is the problem
is once something is in the public
domain then of course it is extremely
difficult to have anything other than a
public finding at the end frankly I've
been quite disgusted to see you know
people just pointing the finger at
pretty where they've no evidence
themselves to see that she has in fact
done any of the things that she's
alleged to have done so you know the
whole concept of innocent until proven
guilty has to be preserved and so I do
genuinely think it's important that it's
independent and confidential and I think
going forward that has to be the case
you are the business secretary now with
your business hat on coronavirus one in
five workers off work at the peak when
it Peaks businesses are going to
struggle aren't they so I mean there's
there's a huge amount to be done to
ensure that businesses are protected and
actually ironically I think a lot of the
work we did last year preparing for the
supposed No Deal brexit on 31st of
October has stood the government in
incredibly good stead looking at you
know packages of support and how you
might be able to help companies to keep
going
should something you know
it happened what would you do for the
army of the self-employed workers and
also the gig economy workers I'm aware
of the difficulty of actually helping
someone who's self-employed because
you're not actually paid in the same way
as someone on PA why he is paid but
nevertheless there could be some support
for your business and that would be
something if I were still business
secretary I would be wanting to look at
it in the immediate all of those gig
economy workers do you think that they
should be able to access some form of I
do if that if that can be made to work
yes I do
one family in your constituency of the
dumb family they're still desperately
trying to get just that justice for
their son he was killed by an American
diplomat driving on the wrong side of
the road you'll know this case extremely
well answer coolest back in the US she's
unlikely to return now to the UK to face
justice despite the family's best
efforts what would you do now have you
at the dom family i appealed directly to
answer coulis to see the absolute
devastation that this accident accident
no one says for one moment that it was
deliberate but this accident and her
actions resulting from it have
devastated the family they just are in
pieces and so I just urge her directly
to come back to the UK and to enable
them to get some closure can't get her
back though we can't force her back can
we the US have refused to release her
and I deeply regret that I do have to
say that Harry's family absolutely
promised him on the day he died that
they would get justice for him and so I
this will not go away this will never go
away you surprised the Prime Minister
hasn't met the dom family you know that
that is for him to decide and you know i
have in representing the duns I've asked
him to see them and it may be that he
will do but it is a matter for him to
decide